méthode rapide original et sanitaires
pour présenter son autorisation de
déplacement dérogatoire collé à la vitre
ou présenter directement aux forces de
l'ordre
les gendarmes contrôlent les
autorisations dans le contexte du
confinement sur ce carrefour de saint
rémy les chevreuse et votre attestation
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
tout ça c'est michel d'associations de
jeunes mourir
et puis de sony d'accord très bien en
moyenne les gens sont quand même assez
assez respectueux ils ont tous leur
attestation tous un motif valable pour
être dehors pour le moment de mon côté
j'ai pas fait de verbalisation
aujourd'hui sur ce poste faire ses
courses déplacements professionnels les
situations les plus fréquentes sur ce
point de contrôle
quelques piétons aussi ou des sportifs
la plupart acceptent la situation donc
il faut une attestation par jour avec la
raison pour laquelle vous déplacer voilà
français pour la prochaine fois
bonne journée monsieur franck orage sera
au revoir je me suis contrôlé trois fois
cette fois ci c'est le quatrième le
contrôle c'est normal c'est c'est
logique c'est leur métier puis quand
date la pour
pour les aider aussi composée de 23
gendarmes la brigade de chevreuse
intervient sur huit communes
les contrôles ont commencé mardi 17 mars
à 13h une dizaine d'agents mobilisés à
travers trois patrouilles
mardi après midi une table de pédagogie
la population active
patron emblématique particulière la
population plus âgée a effectivement
comment je fais pour récupérer mon
attestation je n'ai pas internet je n'ai
pas d'imprimante donc mettre en place
aussi avec les mairies des systèmes pour
que les personnes âgées puissent avoir
leur attestation la partie qui est un
axe d'effort pour nous et d'engagement
c'est les parcs publics les jardins
voilà où les gens ont tendance à se
regrouper une attitude plus répressive a
été adoptée depuis mercredi sur trois
jours depuis le début du confinement
cette brigade a établi cinq procès
verbaux sur plus de 1200 personnes
contrôlées